hi guys welcome to vlog university i'm
justine and we're in las vegas
so i just spent the past hour two hours
watching videos of you guys making fun
of me hey guys justine here in last
week's homework assignment it was to
make a video imitating either me or my
co-host of escape routes rossi i'm i
justine of course no i just seen
impersonation video would be complete
without a few apple store dances
these are probably a couple of my
favorite videos because you guys have
pretty much
nailed spot on some of the random quirks
anyway so
i am going to a yoga class tonight i
have to edit ask ij it looks like a
little reindeer
little reindeer for christmas
i also got me a macbook duh i mean i
sleep with this thing almost every night
and even used a few phrases that i
definitely overuse oh
the thing
showbreezy anyways i'm so excited
that's it for this vlog um yeah okay bye
guys and this just absolutely creeped me
out because i actually thought it was me
in the intro
well the good news is you've ever needed
an ijustine double i have plenty of them
out there no no no
rossi did you think that we forgot about
you oh no no no no hey guys thanks for
tuning in rossi here oh don't take my
picture don't take my picture okay and
this guy is pretty much spot on rossi
morielli to the t
good morning teams how are you doing
today
yeah
all right
now onto your homework assignment for
the next episode most of you guys know
that i've been on the road with a show
called escape routes and we've been
doing all kinds of crazy challenges in
cities across the u.s you guys need to
create a video re-enacting anything that
happened on the show from a challenge to
making fun of any of the contestants and
if you actually need to catch up on some
episodes i'll put a link below and if
you happen to be outside the us and
unable to watch them here is a link to
my playlist of vlog recaps of everything
that we've done don't forget make your
video add it as a video response to this
video and check out escape routes.com
and enter it under challenges then show
and tell for a chance to win a camera
alright i love you
bye
you